gentlemen we're live
so that's that's become cemented already
today our guest is eb tucker an expert
on gold he wrote a book called why gold
why now the war against your wealth and
how to win it he's got a bunch of props
here i bought a free a few props myself
as well
for us to talk about i'm going to ask
him a question in regards to what's a
better investment baseball cards
collectible cards i just recently saw uh
uh aaron rodgers stood up against the
nfl i liked it so much i went about his
best card okay there's only 25 of these
in the world i got one of them it's a
psa 10. it's a good 25 30 000 card and
i'm banking on him doing well for
himself so we'll talk about collectible
cards and then we'll talk about gold is
gold
really oh
you see that
that's uh three counts of gold
wait wait that that football card of
aaron rodgers in a practice jersey is
worth 30 grand this is 30 grand feel
this guy yeah that is heavy as hell and
then we got crypto as well bitcoin you
got some opinions about krypton as well
it's a real thing i mean i call it the
national sweepstakes
wonka i mean everybody knows somebody
that their their friends coin they have
went up to a penny from a tenth of a
penny and they hope they're next you
notice everyone's distracted by this
it's a national distraction so you think
it's a national distraction it is it's
like a sweepstakes i mean i mean i know
guys that run plumbing business all
these things and they're looking at
their phone a hundred times a day
is pizza coin gonna go
to a penny i mean oh my friend's coin
went to a penny maybe it'll go you know
you see how this is everybody's enamored
with this well i mean it's good that you
don't have strong opinions against
bitcoin
the fact that you're very diplomatic we
like that we welcome that here and we're
going to uh deeper into it folks we got
a lot of topics trump had some things to
say about the general millie uh some
clips came out with him calling him what
did he call him he called him a good guy
good guy
adam can you tell everybody
john really i don't care so i would
never
ever repeat what donald j trump had to
say
trump donald j trump is a saint he's
never done anything wrong by the way
yesterday he had a short clip you had a
moment yesterday in the office yeah
where you said the you you agree with
trump on what he said someone makes
sense i'm going to let them know that
they make sense listen i like the fact
that you're starting to reason it's a
very good sign i'm not going to ask a
lot of questions
i'm not going to ask you a lot of
questions today to give you too much
pressure would be uh
anyway he called him an effort so we'll
talk about that okay cuomo he had a
rough weekend the other cuomo tennis
association cancels a billion dollar
worth of matches in china over missing
players uh peng shui and then at the
same time we got updates for you with
mafia states of america with thousands
of people yesterday at middle of the
night i log on there's a thousand people
on the website watching mafia states of
america binge watching some major names
in hollywood i didn't even tell you
yesterday texted me to watch this whole
thing they're giving me feedback one
guy's a billionaire in hollywood i'll
fill you in about this afterwards
they're pretty sick pretty pretty sick
on what they're thinking also and then
because of mafia states of america all
three cuomo's that had a rough weekend
when uh the word
about uh
papa mario
yeah mario that's right so and then aoc
and mansion both on the same side but
disagree immensely on what's going on
right now with the economy and theft and
we got a bunch of things to talk about
with the coins bitcoins gold
uh and then this one story the bad guys
are winning okay which you really want
to get into we will
and one of the things i added here that
i want to talk about is with china
threatening u.s over expected diplomatic
olympic boycott china will take firm
counter measures what that means we
don't know yet but having said that
let's get right into it eb for folks who
don't know take 30 seconds or a minute
tell us your background
well i i put together uh
kind of a career in the gold business
almost by accident i mean when i
discovered gold 20 years ago or so i was
immediately fascinated i mean you pick
up one of these coins and wait a minute
why is it so heavy like you guys were
saying the bar so check this out yeah
that was actually the wealthiest i've
ever been in my life holding that bar in
my hand this is a this is a strange
thing and then then you realize that
this comes out of the earth i mean it
takes two or three thousand pounds of
dirt to
to process to make this one coin you
know like two or three thousand thousand
yeah yeah i mean a ton a ton of gold
will give you like three grams a ton of
dirt will give you like three grams of
gold and so when i saw that i mean i was
fascinated and then
your company finds gold and the stock
goes up you know 10 times and that
caught my attention and i said i got to
figure out how old what do you mean
company finds gold yeah
yeah like say they say mining they're
looking for gold okay so they're looking
for gold and they go out and they they
find it and they say we found a gold
mine and their stock goes crazy and you
get kind of gold fever you know there's
shows you watch deadwood or some show
about this it's real you know and so i
figured that out and then i got into
that business and and then i realized
that that's a bad business because most
people don't find gold you know just
like most people's crypto coin doesn't
go up uh and so anyway so i discovered
the the royalty business and that's what
the book is really about the war against
your wealth and how to win it you know
is we are in a war against against our
efforts to build wealth you know we're
under attack and you guys know that and
so i discovered the royalty business
where all my money is and and so we've
created these long-term royalties on
various different types of assets and uh
it's a business i'm enthusiastic about
so i wrote the whole book so that
everyone can understand that and and so
we look to take a royalty on the gold
output from a mine you know which is
very different you don't pay for any you
can have strikes uh you can have floods
you can all these things happen we don't
pay for any of that you know it's just a
carried interest
in the in the mind so that's how my
career kind of evolved and here we are
today with
outright craziness in the world right
yeah we want to get into that crazy part
who would have predicted all these
things yeah 20 years ago how do we know
this is real how do we know when you
when you hold a gold coin like that how
do you know it's real i don't know so
the best way to do the i like coins
because they're very hard to fake so
like nobody's going to really nobody's
going to really put in the time and the
effort you know and you put one coin on
your finger and you
kind of hit it together you can hear
this sound it's very unique sound that
it makes it's called the ping test you
know if you go into a to a pawn shop the
first thing they'll do is they'll ping
the coins together and they'll listen
for that unique sound problem with the
bars is that a couple years ago the
chinese were putting tungsten cores in
the bar so it has a similar weight to
gold and then they were putting gold in
the outside that goes all the way back
to the roman empire when they tried
exactly exactly right so are you saying
the chinese can't be trusted when it
comes to that
but they can be they can be because the
chinese are very intense about gold so
the chinese they don't let any gold
leave the country they're the biggest
producer in the world of gold so but
they don't let any gold that they
produce leave the country why is that
what's their argument they they want it
in country they want gold so whereas
americans they produce gold in nevada
and just leaves the country you know the
the chinese are like no no no no why
though why do they want it they see it
as real wealth they see it as real yeah
so obviously listen we got a lot of
things to go through here with the uh
coins crypto
you know collectible cards but in
regards to what's been happening lately
you got a lot of people like charlie
munger wasn't too happy about crypto you
heard the comments that he made about
matter of fact i'll read it to you guys
to see what he had to say
about crypto first time agreeing with
what china is doing
charlie munger who's a partner warren
buffett he's a billionaire goes off on
crypto says china made the right
decision when they banned it this is a
fortune story for all the recent buzz
surrounding crypto investment charlie
munger is just not buying it and he
doesn't want any crypto traders marrying
into his family either believe me
the people who are getting into
cryptocurrency are not thinking about
the customer they're thinking about
themselves just look at them i wouldn't
want any of them to marry into my family
he also said that he supports china's
crack crackdown
on cryptocurrency and frowned upon the
us's heavy involvement with her the
chinese made the correct decision which
is just simply banned them and he
slammed bitcoin specifically of course i
hate the bitcoin success i don't welcome
a currency that's so useful to
kidnappers and extortionists and so
forth nor do i like
just shuffling out of your extra
billions of dollars to somebody who just
invented a new financial product out of
thin air so
obviously you agree with charlie but if
you want to go a little bit deeper into
what he's saying old man yells it's not
totally fair to say i agree with him but
but but i think his comments are
important because remember in my book i
have a whole section on how crypto came
to be okay so it's very important that
people realize i mean back when bitcoin
was a dollar i knew about it so
what you have to understand is the value
of the coin
and the platform are mutually exclusive
and what that means is is that the
platform is very important to understand
blockchain technology is how you will
transact all business in the future like
you buy a piece of property right now
you have a title agent you have doc
stamps you have a little lady that's
pressing your thing down into the county
it's
it was never meant to be a speculative
currency exactly so so so when people
talk about investing in crypto they're
not investing okay they're speculating
that the value of the coin is going to
go up and they're going to sell it to
somebody else who's going to want the
coin there's like 10 000 coins i mean
you go on coin gecko or whatever the
site is ten thousand coins okay these
are useless
utterly useless now what percentage are
you using a high high percentage a high
percentage
i would say if you really want to own
crypto you own ethereum first you own a
little bit of bitcoin and you leave the
rest alone like none of it
because
did i make the ethereum argument last
week i want to see why he's going to say
that makes you curious because you take
okay a smart contract like like with
your house you have title insurance what
is title insurance it says that that if
there's a problem with the title later
that they'll ensure that you actually
bought the title and whatever that's all
solved by blockchain so like smart
contracts you're talking about there's a
zero value for title insurance ten years
from now the currency is the contract
too it's like when pat was buying his
house and it was a three-day process for
him to sign a deal that's now just the
coin that's right so what should gerard
do with all his dogecoin though
well that's that's
that's a that's a guy
yeah
which coin will make it i mean who who
knows right because remember musk comes
out and makes dogecoin a thing
now it's not a thing it's gone you said
it was a not a scam but it was uh
so what do you say on snl but look
that's like stock promotion i mean
imagine if somebody's it's weird right
it's weird you come out and you're like
you know what if my company's metallic
or some mta if i was like you know
metalliz uh if i started saying all
these things about how it's going to go
to the moon right the sec shuts me down
i can't be on a board i can't say
anything unless you're in congress then
it's fine well yeah it's very popular by
the way this is a very good point here
this is a very good point he's making
you can't go claim that your stock or an
investment's going to go to the moon but
you can with crypto yeah yeah and a lot
of people do that yeah that's true
think about it the rock came out
tomorrow and was like shiba you know to
the moon and he owns a million shebo's
and it goes up one decimal point he's a
deca billionaire this goes back to the
joseph kennedy model back in the days
when he made the stock market crash and
fdr brought him in because he knew all
the ways of manipulating the stock
market and then they added controls to
it so the challenge with the crypto
community that they come back and they
say well the government cannot touch it
they've already been trying to touch it
and then i get some of the private
equity guys that say let me tell you
what people are doing in private equity
right now because the tax code would
crypto you can buy take a loss buy again
you can do double tax write-offs over
and over they're not going to let that
last too long of a time isn't that the
beauty of the market like school costs
money man if you get caught in a pump
and dump you get caught once okay it
happens yeah twice that's all you you
i'm
but what i'm trying to say to you is you
really believe and elizabeth warren and
aoc a bernie sanders and nancy pelosi is
going to allow that to happen you think
they're going to let that happen
constantly in the crypt you don't think
these guys are eventually going to want
to over regulate the crypto community of
course i do but right they're trying now
and they can't figure it out they're
getting you used to this so everybody is
accepted the fact that they can have a
wallet they can have digital money all
their money can be on the grid all these
people who talk about cryptos off the
grid they're completely wrong
like the kid in orlando that was hacking
people's twitters remember and taking
yeah of course they caught him they
showed up at his house yeah how did they
do that i found him like very quickly
very quickly and he had sent the bitcoin
all over the world to be split and
washed yeah this is on the grid anybody
who thinks they're off the grid just
needs to research why because they're on
platforms like coinbase or
gemini
the blockchain is infinitely traceable
and controllable and where this is which
is the point of the blockchain correct
where this all ends is fedcoin and in
the book this is this is a term that i
came up with about six years ago fedcoin
is what we'll use to pay for everything
and it will be easy to get people
accepted and what i think this is
somewhat controversial but i think all
these stable coins
ultimately are going to crash and then
fedcoin will be what they bring like the
phoenix they bring out the same like the
tether the us that's right i think those
are going to crash and then it's all
just going to be and i think it might be
pre-designed crash where basically
they say okay everyone's into this now
all right but as you can see there were
some speculative problems like the
private market so the fed will control
this but wait do you think some shadowy
international pseudo government would
organize some sort of doomsday event
never to increase never
never but imagine if you if we are the
elite okay so we say right now okay we
would let people be free but nonsense
because what happens when you get to
that level is you try to consolidate
power all the time you're worried about
threats and so look at fedcoin i can
control everything you do
taxation you can no longer avoid being
taxed because all of your money is on
the so they're going to nationalize
crypto is what you're saying in other
words they'll pick a crypto winner
that's infinitely you know the
blockchain is distributed ledger that's
the technology but when you have fedcoin
it's controlled ledger so mit makes one
server that controls the entire fedcoin
ecosystem on a quantum computer and
every single fedcoin is documented and
you you've been really naughty so no
more leisure activities oh yeah with
your social uh social engineering social
studies okay so let me ask you so let's
just say we go in that direction who
wins who loses
well i think people that are close to
power win okay what we're transitioning
to is a command economy so this is what
china has and i think the us is envious
of china because china's control is so
great command economy yeah a command
economy so in a command economy where
you want to be issued opposed to a
market economy is that the that's long
gone so in in a market economy there's
price discovery and what happens is is
that price discovery creates the value
of everything and the market it produces
different solutions you know to solve
different problems we left that behind a
long time ago right now command economy
is is controlled by fiat it's controlled
by committee and if you look at how
things are going in the u.s the
narrative comes out the news story
narrative comes out the policy is set
and then people like us say we debate
about these things but it's it's
pointless because is this like a
communism rebrand a command economy it's
exciting
communism trying to be it's trying to be
uh communism with the idea of free
market principles because if you look in
america everybody's like oh this is a
this is a free market is it really a
free market i mean
oh we can vote here it's really it's
really this is great because we choose
our elected leaders do we really choose
our elected leaders at every turn all
the things people say if you really
question them so let me ask you they're
falling apart i i'm sensing a
threat here similar to peter schiff so
are you saying
we stopped being a
market economy free enterprise where you
can go out there and do everything when
it was based on a gold standard and now
it's a command economy it could be
because it's based on fiat are you going
to the 1972 no is that kind of where
you're going
and peter's a friend i mean he's he's
our our biggest shareholder in our
company you know he's really a trip to
hang out with because he's he has a
different take on this that than i have
i mean so i don't think the gold
standard really matters that much i mean
the government has you know nuclear
powered
aircraft carrier battle groups and they
tell you this is the dollar and okay
it's the dollar i i call it the lead
standard yeah we're on the led stand
yeah exactly that's what we're going to
we're going to use spedcoin they can do
the same thing you say you use fedcorn
you starve i mean that that's the deal
you know like you're going to do it so
what happens to the actual us dollar if
this fed coin comes to existence i don't
think it matters i mean i think what we
see is like interest rates started
falling at the turn of the century like
they're negative right now they're going
to keep going down everybody's like oh
they're going to go up the government's
going to have a hard time financing
itself no it's not going to happen it's
not going to happen the deal is you can
control this this is a controlled
demolition and so this system will
continue going down the average person
right now one percent in the savings
account ten percent inflation they're
losing nine percent per year oh man we
got momentum come on i'm curious here
yeah i'm curious about what he's saying
it's it's uh
all right
we're on
okay all right let us know if you're on
or not the entire building folks went
down so are we are we live can somebody
tell us if you can hear us or not give
it a thumbs up if you can hear a smash
that thumbs button if you can
how much money is on the table right now
well these are these are a thousand
grams is um
maybe
30 30 ounces 30 32 ounces is this an
ounce that's that's more than an ounce
that that's a i like these announces
the mexican 1800 what is that what it is
1800 1780 we're back on we're back on
okay folks we don't know what's going on
here with this going live the whole
building came down they don't want this
album yeah well we'll see i mean i don't
know if this can gerard saying this may
be china this may be the fed this may be
the
whoever it is we're going to go back to
it okay let me let me let me ask you a
question that i think the market is
wondering right now let's see what your
opinion is going to be on this so the
the question becomes gold versus bitcoin
gold folks are screaming off the top of
their lungs let me tell you about
gold and inflation's coming and gold
prices are going to go up and nothing
happened it went lower right so this
article here by bloomberg
says gold or bitcoin store of value
debate rages as bitcoin grows the gold
camp cites the metals long history
versus bitcoin's instability and lack of
regulatory support grayscale and bitcoin
backers say the cryptocurrency has
digital gold with superior efficiency
and potential
gold has better applications in some
cases than bitcoin and others bitcoin is
more transportable and divisible and
more applicable as a currency but gold
is more stable
with a proven track record both offer
virtually no correlation to traditional
asset classes with gold's correlation is
at zero and still bitcoin is currently
most aptly characterized as a
speculative asset gold and bitcoin have
different long-term tax uh u.s tax rates
for short-term capital gains on
investment bought and sold within a year
both are taxed at the individual income
tax rate bitcoin is taxed in the same
way as stock ownership with a long-term
capital tax gains tax rate of zero to 20
depending on income levels gold is taxed
as a collectible and therefore carries a
long-term rate of 28 so that's a big
difference right there irrespective of
an investor's income so what is your
biggest
what would you say is why someone should
own some gold versus crypto when you
when you so so i i have a bloomberg
terminal i have you know probably more
information than than any any person how
much is a bloom so people don't know
what that means 39 30 grand a year years
yeah so so plus you know i i've got
access to i probably read about 3 000
pages of hedge fund research a year i
know all these people what i want people
to do when they read a news story is
realize that the story is written to
distract you with details and to confuse
you while pushing a narrative okay so
when you read stories when you get to a
level where you've been doing this 20
years you've read millions of pages of
paper
all you're doing is saying what's the
narrative what's the narrative okay and
then what do i need to do to get around
the narrative so the narrative is is
that gold is dumb and bitcoin is smart
okay so there's a big push where we want
you in crypto okay and what we're saying
is you don't need this this is stupid
it's hard to transport you don't need
this it doesn't do anything
technologically you go back and read
stories earlier in the year gold's going
up gold going down bitcoin's going up so
there's always this support of you don't
want this you want the crypto so we want
you in crypto it's we know where your
money is the thing about this is is that
nobody knows that this is here okay i
can melt this down all right i can make
a belt buckle out of it or a bracelet or
something like that walk across a border
and turn it back into a coin and i have
not lost one atom of gold not one
molecule of gold has been lost in that
process this is infinitely fungible okay
and people have used this for years to
store as a store of wealth it's not an
investment gold is not an investment it
doesn't go up in value okay it
represents other things that go down in
value there's a finite amount of this in
the world now go back to 2000 gold's 250
275 dollars it's gone to 2080. if you
look at a chart it's performed very very
well in fact
it's beaten stocks if you go back to
2000 to the first of the year 2000 but
it's deceptive because we were in a
crazy time for stocks right then but
gold has held up great and so it's
bought you about the same amount of
equity
over that time and so everybody's hooked
on speculation right now but it's not
about speculation my book is not about
buy some coins and make a fortune it's
about it's a war against your wealth
so wealth and speculating are different
and so when you get down to it you
realize all these arguments are made in
the press about bitcoin people say well
you know there's a finite amount there's
a it's limited to 21 million it's all
the stuff it's you can put it on a thumb
drive whatever somebody might steal it
you know okay so you got to be careful
about that which exchange you're going
to have all you get down to it this is
wealth
and everybody that has serious money
knows it all the elites of the world
know it the chinese know it why do you
think they won't let you export it the
russians know it everybody but the
governments who who bank bank into uh
gold they're not looking at making
28 or 12 or eight percent a year they're
looking at making two three four percent
per year they're not aggressively
investing in you know that's when you
have treasury bonds which is going to
give you what pretty much nothing over a
30-year period yeah negativity yeah
that's right yeah i can see why
governments would be interested in
something like this but the average
investor why would the app you're
talking to a guy that these are mine and
i have some more as well i'm just
telling i've got a few things to show
you so you're not talking to
a person that doesn't hold gold or
currency right or crypto i'm a believer
i'm open but why should someone buy it
if it's just the currency so everybody
that's listening to this show yeah wants
to learn okay that's why they're
listening to the show is they're seeking
these are these are people with drive
okay and you're the same way and so what
you know is that you only have to get
rich once in life once you get rich then
you have to stay rich this very
different type of thinking you know
you're not speculating you know you get
to a certain level you're not like what
can i speculate on maybe with a little
bit right but you also are playing
defense and so once you've you've
listened to shows like this you've
learned you've educated yourself you've
hustled you've paid all this tax you've
done all these things what are you gonna
do
what are you gonna do this is the war
against your wealth and so when you get
into that mindset you realize i need
some wealth in something
that's safe
something that has defense that plays
defense now my company metal royalty
that's different because if gold goes up
the value of 30 years of gold production
goes up dramatically i mean it's it's
highly highly leveraged what do you mean
to the price of gold so if i have a mine
that's going to produce a hundred
thousand ounces a year for 30 years and
i get one percent of that if you look at
the out years and the one percent's
worth 100 more per ounce the value of
that pulled back into today is gigantic
i mean imagine if you bought an
apartment and it gets a thousand dollars
a month and that is going to go up by 50
a year what's that worth 30 years from
now i mean the number is humongous and
so that's different from owning a
physical coin okay so then so then one
thing i would say in regards to this is
i think the gold community
uh uh let's just throw peter out there
because he's one of the loudest ones
when it comes down to gold and he sells
gold and he's all about gold and our own
gold all this stuff i think it is a
mistake to compete directly with crypto
i think it's a big mistake if from the
purely from a marketing standpoint i
think it's a massive mistake because the
angle you just took
i came to you like this you went this
way you didn't even fight me for it you
just said listen you're not buying this
because of this i remember one time i
sat down with the moody family i don't
know if you know the moody family their
billionaire family out of
uh uh uh uh out of houston i think
they're out of galveston and i went and
sat down family that does the ratings
the
moody like uh national western like
american and you know all these
insurance companies and they're very
well off they own a bunch of banks if
you go to texas to moody's bank
everywhere
so i pitched him an idea we sat down um
we went for a couple hours i said here's
what i think we ought to do to get a
partnership this is 12 years ago
and he said to me you know patrick
there's two different types of people
i said what's that he says there's
guys that wake up every morning wanting
to make their first billion and then
there's guys that are billionaires
trying to keep their billion i'm the
second guy you're the first guy i'm not
doing a deal my family is counting on me
to keep our money i'm not trying to make
another billion dollars i'm trying to
keep our family wealth
what you're saying is that's gold that's
defensive strategy
nobody should buy this saying imagine if
the 60 000
bar is one day a million dollars that's
the crypto sale
i think you're buying this similar to a
sale of life insurance
god forbid just in case something were
to happen you want to hedge yourself
against a massive risk right right i
think that's the same turn it back into
new money later i mean that was the
whole like you look at other historical
societies where people walked across a
border and this was what got them
something to eat in a different society
we're living in though well in some ways
it is in some ways it's not right i mean
you think meadow's the future in some
ways no i don't think so i think i think
i think this is the type of thing you
hope you don't need it
you hope that your wealth continues to
grow you continue to speculate all these
things happen you hope you don't need
this but what i'm saying in my book is
like if you think about how much of this
you should have it's a much lower number
than you think i mean two or three
percent of your wealth is probably
sufficient so is that the number that
you're encouraging people to yeah i mean
you want to be careful because i don't
give
direct advice in there but i give people
a formula that i make you know and the
number i come up with is two or three
percent is plenty i mean you know i have
your entire network yeah i mean if
you're a millionaire you should have 20
30 points yeah it's that's how much you
should put into getting gold it's a lot
it's a lot i mean you because what what
does this do right here it does nothing
except it protects that money so if you
go
if you go and you turn that back into
money in the future it gives you about
the same buying power
why did you buy this
let me ask you the the doomsday question
all right and this is the doomsday
question this is not every day so the
idea to hedge gold against an
apocalyptic event where the economy
crashes
and uh you know the country becomes
insolvent now you still have some sort
of fungible asset to go and buy medicine
buy food why not just get a gun instead
okay but this is the thing i think
people need to understand as they read
the book is that it's already crashing
so you have a system it's called
capitalist system that means that it's
based on capital has the value we're
really not capitalization exactly
capital capital right now has no value
there's immense amounts of capital okay
look at the life insurance business like
it's not the same business it was 50
years ago because you can't get a return
on capital it it completely makes that
business turns it on its head right
because
you have negative real rates of return
and people don't understand that like i
tried to explain it in the book i'm like
look you're getting one percent go to
the grocery store it's ten percent more
expensive than last year no no people
inflation's only six percent exactly
it's whatever they say it is right and
so and so what people what people are
are going to realize in a few years is
that it's the crash has already happened
a sideways crash is the same as a as a
down crash and you're in this sideways
crash now can you google price of gold
kilo type in price of gold kilo and go
to the second link that's goldprice.org
yeah go to gold
all right let's see go to the second one
right there 60 grand
and then click on when it comes up go
down
and go to 20 years when you go to the
site there's 180 grand on the table
so
the thing that's a good time to make a
run for it that's kind of dope
caroline left
i wish i had better cardio go up and
take the three days and make that three
days go down go down go down right below
the chart
to right in the middle of the black one
where it says three days go a little
lower it says three days right there
says three days to the right
oh my god hi buddy come on tyler it says
three days right here
30 days three days right here it says
three days go to 20 years go to 20 years
you know pat ain't happy when he stands
up and points it's the first time i
stood up even though
that's been going away uh
trainer pat's looking good these days he
wanted to show up
all right so that's not that that's
about what's happened the opposite of
what's happened to your money now pat
let's let's real quick real quick sure
this is a 20 bill okay and this was
exchangeable for one ounce of gold like
if you look at this what year was this i
had to pay about four hundred dollars
for that for this yeah okay so so that
and and this one dollar bill was
exchangeable for an ounce of silver okay
and and so
this is for how much of gold one ounce
so that that give you would give you
this okay the bank would exchange it for
you that was the law what year uh it
says this was 1957.
pretty epic point he's about to make
about all right ready so this one ounce
of gold okay this ounce of gold has not
changed it came from nevada this is a
u.s eagle so it has to all come from the
u.s so this is a one one ounce piece of
gold one ounce is one ounce always it
has not changed now today i'm going to
show you what it takes to buy an ounce
of gold okay we're gonna have to make
some more room on the table because
the ounce of gold has not changed at all
since since the 20s and the amount of
cash that it takes to buy the ounce of
gold
continues to grow and the reason why i
think this relates to your chart there
is that people need to ask themselves
what's their the trajectory of that
chart these are all singles this is
singles but the reason it's the great
point he's making so he got on someone
he just did it's important to to do it
with singles because because
that's how you you priced right here i
mean that it's in dollars this is our
currency so singles are important i mean
if i just brought you know 20 100 bills
here i mean that's you know
it's we say dollars we don't price
things in hundreds of dollars you know
we say dollars and and this pile is
going to continue to grow yeah i mean
why would it not
why would it not we're in a debt based
system
so why would it not continue to be
powerful point you just made right there
did you see what just happened right
there so
this one dollar would buy you a silver
coin okay this one dollar bill 19.56
1934 this would buy you a silver coin so
how much is a silver 23 so 23 bucks from
three here's what's great is that with
silver that's a whole different ball
game because you've got to pay a
significant premium to get the coin
like you got to pay another six or seven
dollars to get the silver coin
that's what's so bizarre right they're
like silver's 22 but yeah the coin's 30.
why would buffett put 35 million in
silver that's a long that was in the 90s
that's complicated you know that was
with fibro and there was yeah i mean he
tried he saw this and he tried to corner
and then and then he had to come off
that yeah yeah so so this right here 20
bucks in 1922 to buy a coin of gold
right yeah an ounce of gold same amount
how much is an ounce of gold same amount
it's 1800 so that's 90x since 1922. yeah
same coin
coin hasn't changed at all to give you
an idea what this 90 x means 1922
that's exactly 100 years in about a
couple weeks right so let's go 100 years
that means by 2122
that coin right there that's worth how
much right now eighteen hundred eighteen
hundred times ninety is what one point
uh seven million one point six million
now now here's here's what's sad okay
because i know this is
you just your sentimental guy you can
appreciate 162.
your ancestor had saved up a thousand
dollars for you and put it in an
envelope and left you that thousand
dollars i mean
if we went and got a couple seafood
towers for lunch we would spend the
thousand dollars you know in one hour
okay
but if that same thousand dollars if
they put 50 ounces of gold
think about think about the difference
generational wealth yeah so this is this
is one of those you know how your
parents you know when we were in school
they're like you know buy these coins
set it aside give it to your kids 30
years from now or something like that i
remember one time the uncirculated
nickels do you remember that whole
uncertainty yeah i got a case of
uncirculated nickels about 20 years ago
for 500 bucks yeah and i don't know if
you've seen these uncirculated nickels
you ever seen those things when they
would come out okay so it's literally in
a uh the tube that comes out it's never
been circulated to people you buy five
hundred dollars worth you set it aside
one day i'm going to give it to tcon
dylan and they'll sell it for whatever
20 30 40 000 right
you're saying this is one of those
things two three percent get some of
this set it aside
and like you asked me a question why
about yeah here's why i bought gold so
you know for me i have around uh
seven million dollars worth of cards is
what i have okay
and the reason why i like cards is
because to me there's only 25 of these
in the world this card right here okay
this is aaron rodgers rookie card 05
guy's got the best team in the league
this year some way say that he could win
the super bowl whether he does or not he
leaves he does i'm probably gonna end up
selling this in the next five ten years
for two to five hundred thousand dollars
okay this card right here that i paid
thirty thousand dollars for that's
pretty proven unless if he does
something stupid like an oj story
something like that the return on this
is gonna be pretty high i didn't buy
gold for that reason gold is a buy for
me of end of the world type of a mindset
it's not there's a slightly of defensive
strategy but it's also hits the fan
it's good to have a little bit and when
i mean it's the fan i mean like
cyber warfare insanity crazy stuff not
even this uh you know biowarfare that
people are talking about with you know
with uh covet i'm talking cyber because
we have an experienced cyber cyber is
going to be a lot scarier than it's
going to be with kovic because cyber
you're going to be like
i can't even touch my money just notice
for a minute here we didn't have
internet how we felt you felt helpless
for like five minutes right yep okay
what are we doing what do we do imagine
if you can't touch your
money you can't make a transaction think
about that's this all right let's go
there let's go that's coming over the
end of the decade by the way so that's
that's
that's coming that's the thing you're
pretty certain about it when you make a
make a uh a claim like that you seem
pretty confident about it that's the
next chapter because if you look i want
you i'm always watching people okay and
i don't like to have my phone and i
watch these people they're glued to the
phone right they cannot live without the
phone they have a panic attack if they
don't have the phone all their
information they get from the phone so
we're dependent with the phone and so if
you think about it if you want total
control of the society you already have
people bought into their money being
digital on the phone so you get that
going now no one can function without
this and then you throw a crash in there
and you say to people well unfortunately
the system was vulnerable it was hacked
everyone's in panic and what we're gonna
need to do is have an implantable uh
identification device that makes it to
where you know this can never happen
again and everybody will say i'm i'm in
put it in me
can you see this happening yeah for sure
before before we move on though the one
thing i did want to point out to people
you showed twenty dollars one ounce of
gold in 1920. tyler can you pull up real
quick what the average salary was in
the average salary was thirty four
thousand no no no
32.69 3 269. yeah okay that sounds and
what's what's the average salary today
60. 30 34 30. that's not the right
number
it's 2012. 2012. so it was 30
hundred 30.
twenty x yeah twenty two twenty twenty x
today yeah but the money ninety x the
gold ninety yeah that gold is ninety
eight what i'm saying when it was
tethered to money absolutely so the
actual rate of the money that you earn
is one-third of what it was a hundred
years sure right so the hours of your
life for people that don't understand
what they're seeing right for maybe like
somebody that's younger that doesn't
understand like okay like whatever i'm
just trying to pay bills i don't care
about investing dude what this shows is
that you need to work three
times as many hours to get the same
amount of tangible wealth as somebody
did in 1920. so so so pat you're you're
a numbers guy i've i've put my entire
net worth and my entire life effort into
grabbing
decades
of
exposure to this going up a little tiny
bit in value so like you go to 2500 on
this which i think is like completely
doable it's not a it's not a big ask to
see this go to 2 500. people per ounce
for a yeah
like that people waking up so you're
waking up right now like this is all
boom it's all hitting right now and as
people wake up to this 2500 is
completely in the cards and i've got
decades of exposure to that coming out
of the ground with no exposure to cost
yeah but you're playing a different game
you're not the average guy though so to
the average guy listening to you robin
hood account guy can buy one share of
the stock period it's
avoid seven dollars i mean it's like you
know you're in i mean sure yes stock but
you're you're making the money in a
different way you've hedged yourself in
a v you position yourself in a a
completely different game the one
percent that you're gonna make uh uh
regardless you're in a very good
position but here's here's the biggest
part for me what i took away from this
exchange was the following
as a marketer
i think
eighty percent of gold's sales people
are selling it the wrong way as a
marketer i think they're selling it the
wrong way i remember earlier
uh uh this in 2010 2011 everybody
started selling gold i don't know if you
remember that or not okay yeah it's
going to five thousand it's going to
five thousand six mr t was doing
commercials oh i mean i remember that
the guys were brothers
guys were making real money so so
remember how the correlation we might so
this is the next thing i want to get
into with you so we talk about what
causes communists communism membership
to go up what causes membership to go up
like the highest level of membership and
communism in america was when after the
1929 you know inflationary great
depression and everybody joined the
communist movement this is when the
whole
political stories you hear about reagan
sag president we got to get the
communists out of hollywood and then all
of a sudden people are like dude we're
not interested in communism this doesn't
work so membership went dramatically
down right so to me there is a
cause and effect when it comes down to
memberships to communism when it comes
down to real estate going up and down
inflation goes up real estate prices
goes down unless if your real estate is
in a position where it's always going to
do well because there's a demand water
community near a school near whatever
right
the part that's been confusing the last
18 months
has been
the typical things that makes gold move
hasn't moved right so it's going the
opposite it's going the opposite so what
do you think is going on because well
back to your point i mean that you
you've got to somehow learn how to think
opposite in markets if you want to make
money like when remember the stories joe
kennedy was like the shoeshine guy he's
giving him a stock tip and he goes and
shorts the whole market and makes a
fortune a generational fortune right
because he was playing the opposite we
have the sec because of that guy that
guy is what started all these
regulations securities industries
yeah his whole thing was like if the
shoeshine guy's in there's nobody else
to get in and so when you look at the
crypto market who else is there to get
in the uber drivers are all uh
well you got the the internet you got
the bros in go get in that elevator out
there and wait for somebody from a
random company in this building and ask
them you got any crypto they're like oh
yeah sure do man i want more i mean
everybody is in so you've got to kind of
think a little bit opposite so like the
whole thing is happening right now like
the whole collapse is happening right
now and nobody wants gold but to your
point of selling gold like in the book i
explained i have my gold dealers listed
in the book right so if you call and say
i read the book and i like to buy an
ounce of gold though i tell you what to
buy like this is the thing you need to
buy the problem is those guys on tv are
selling you collectible coins they're
like well this one commemorates the moon
landing so it's really rare they only
made a million of them you know and you
should buy this and pay double the price
of gold so that's what you got to watch
out for and i explained that in the book
and a lot of the mr t was buying gold
remember it was cash for gold so give us
your gold we'll give you the cash you
know so so okay nobody has an
there's no reason for someone there's
nobody selling this gold like
the the brokers that sell you this coin
right here they make like two or three
percent max i mean it's not much money
it's not like they dug the gold up and
spent a thousand digging it up and then
they sold it to you okay so all the gold
that's ever been mined in human history
fits in a couple of swimming pools i
mean it's not much gold you have to
remember that it's like there's not a
factory making gold selling you the gold
making money there's only twenty percent
that we haven't found that's the number
you hear about there's not fifty
thousand it's falling dramatically yeah
so like and now we have not found that
we have not mined yet so supposedly
okay so look there used to be like a 50
million ounce gold mine found about
every 10 years you know and there hasn't
been one in almost 20 years and there's
no money being spent exploring why bezos
wants to go to the moon
but but see here's the thing okay so so
you go to the moon and you find a lot of
gold and you have to transport it back
here do you know what the esg rating for
the
that mining company is going to be and
it's going to be terrible right because
i mean how are you going to get it back
here you're going to burn rockets to go
back and forth i mean i've been to
they'll be they'll be exempt i've been
to many many many gold mines okay let me
tell you like this is an immense
undertaking i mean you have trucks with
tires that are twice my size driving in
and out of this thing all day long
bringing dump loads of dirt up to the to
the surface two thousand pounds of each
one there's like two grams of gold this
is 32 grams of gold so basically you
have 16 dump trucks coming up to make
one coin i mean come on this represents
real human effort you know this is this
is so the amount of gold being
discovered is going down okay and so and
so you have this looming shortage and
you can see it and to your point was
that the narrative doesn't support it
but i'm telling you when the narrative
does support it we need to be selling
that that's what you got to remember is
that there's going to be a day where all
the guys in the elevator like they want
this
and that's when you are probably trading
this for some fedcoin to start a
business or to do something else right
because it's happening now so like you
want to prepare when did you want to buy
crypto like i remember in the book i
tell an honest story about hearing about
crypto it was 10 bucks and my buddy was
like we could mine this stuff with all
these old computers and i'm like what do
you think i'm an idiot i'm not going to
do that that sounds dumb you know okay
you have the ability to buy the ability
to buy bitcoin at 10 bucks and you're
like i was like i'm not a you know
and i remember when peter schiff was
running for senate you know in freedom
fest 2009 i mean i remember being out
there and there that this was like i was
in this community you know this is i'm
in these scenes where you're hearing
about stuff earlier you know and so i'm
saying to you it sounds you want to
think opposite like when the shoeshine
guy wants the bitcoin it's a little bit
late maybe i mean you can own some it's
not like it's you're not in bitcoin at
all no it's not like it's going to go to
zero don't get me wrong you have zero
encrypted zero crypto yeah zero zero and
how much do you have in silver
uh a lot okay more than you have in gold
no no more gold silver's hard to store
is it two to one
it's i don't know i mean the problem
with the silver is that i ended up with
so much of it that it became a nuisance
i mean you've got like well if you if
you're struggling with it i'm happy to
help you boxes and boxes so where are
you keeping this stuff is my point so no
problem no like a genuine question like
i want to ask you
but that's a question it's like all
right i gotta lug this around if you're
okay
no the the reason why i keep it in a
bank
got off silver was because i ended up
with a storage problem so i've got
silver problem to have all over the
place
that's a very
set aside the sarcasm that's a very
common story here yeah now so what do
you mean i could break that down storage
problem yeah so i mean it's only 200
bucks a coin right i've got like 100 100
ounce silver bars that i've got like as
paper weights just for the hell of it
well explain it to them this way this is
the best part to explain it so one of
these is worth what 60k pretty much okay
how much does sixty thousand dollars
worth of silver take space on this table
the whole table that's the point yeah so
sixty thousand is the whole table gotcha
no
let's just get people to understand
something though silver is very
interesting from an investment
perspective is silver probably goes to
100 at some point an ounce what is it
now 22. so
silver goes wild for a number of reasons
i mean there's not there's a lot of
silver used in solar like i feel like
i've heard that for like 20 years though
i know because i'm talking about hyping
up silver well that's yeah he's on a
different kind of wavelength but
basically the thing about silver that
that you got to know is that silver is a
trade
so gold gold is something you can put in
the safe it takes up no space like you
can own it forever it's not that big of
a deal i mean you're not trying to make
money on it but silver went to 50 in
1980 it went to 50 in 2011. that's going
to be a triple top like there's a huge
problem with production because
there's almost no silver mining it's all
byproduct so it comes from like a copper
mine that produces a little bit of
silver or a zinc mine that produces a
little bit of silver so so silver you
can't go turn up the production on
silver is my point so when silver starts
to go there's a huge shortage of silver
when silver starts to move it goes crazy
and so
i probably
hypothetically would get rid of some of
the silver in that type of move where i
don't see gold going on a 5x move it's i
just i think it's like too extreme i
mean i see gold going to like 2500 and
that you know the royalty company is all
the exposure all over a couple guys here
commenting saying silver is ethereum
gold is bitcoin would you agree with
that well
i think ethereum is better than bitcoin
so it's hard to i don't feel that way
that way i think i think that's the way
they've marketed it but but you know i
think ethereum's much more interesting
than okay let me let me read you this
other article from coin telegraph in
regards to how to hedge against
inflation because that's kind of where i
was going with the question gold bitcoin
or d5 how can investors hedge against
inflation and a note
sent to client strategists at wall
street banking giant jp morgan has
suggested that a one percent portfolio
allocation to bitcoin could serve a
hedge against fluctuations in
traditional asset classes that's jp
morgan that's jamie dimon saying one
percent in bitcoin the decentralized
finance defy
sector is a viable alternative by using
stable coins cryptocurrencies with the
price of a control mechanism and
decentralized applications
investors could outpace inflation while
resisting the risk of a spot position to
do this they simply have to find a way
to earn interest on the stable coins
that would be above annual inflation
rates bitcoin is more attractive as a
store of value than other assets chester
commodities as growing demand can
only be met by rising prices and not
traditional production and then this the
last one gold has underperformed this
year
dropping 8.6
against the dollar while the cpi in the
u.s moved up 6.2 inflation gold-filled
investors who bet on it while btc
bitcoin is up
92.3
year-to-date rewarding those who believe
in it as a hedge thoughts you hear the
narrative yeah you hear the narrative
gold failed you this week so
go with the sit with the bitcoin so we
can track everything that you buy all
right there's 12 trillion dollars with
the gold in the whole world okay so if
if everybody with financial let's say
there's like you know
uh 250 trillion of financial assets in
the world you know okay if one percent
of those tried to go into gold
forget about it it does not exist like
that's the market cap of gold they're
saying it's 12 trillion versus bitcoin
bitcoin is one trillion so it's 12x
bitcoin yeah but look my point is is
that is that if they said
put one percent of your portfolio into
gold in for worldwide
you better have guns because
it doesn't exist like the annual supply
is about 3 000 tons and shrinking okay
there's there's no way like who's going
to give you the gold you know the
government central bank of russia forget
about it like you know all the elite
families of the world you know
mining in our antarctica and deep sea
mining will begin and all that no no way
i mean it's too it's too expensive you
better have 5 000 an ounce to get the
stuff off the bottom of the ocean like
you can forget about it it's not
possible like i'm in the business i'm
telling you that like you you the the
the low value gold to go after is not
there okay and so you read these pieces
and what's the narrative the narrative
is oh you're now worried about inflation
buy crypto that'll protect you you did
nine times because bitcoin's up ninety
percent inflation they say is six it's
really ten okay so you did nine times
better than inflation this year just buy
some bitcoin and boom you're you're good
let me ask you do you ever have dialogue
or debates with staunch crypto or
bitcoin people like a pomp
versus an eb if you guys were debating
right now and you're like oh this is
what it is he's like no you don't
understand bitcoin yeah i don't think
you guys clash what is that conversation
could have a conversation with kurt from
last week i don't think it's right i
don't think it's like better you know i
just i just don't think it accomplishes
the purpose that the narrative tells you
that it accomplishes so do you not own
crypto out of zero no no i mean it's not
spiteful i mean i'm just like look i you
only need one trick in your in your bag
right i mean like i know how to create
wealth on the royalty business model
like i know how to do that and it's
available to everyone it's not like i
created wealth and then took the company
public at peak valuation i used the
public company to buy the royalties so
you could have bought the stock for 80
cents a share u.s when we started you
know it's like up 9x right now okay and
it's had a terrible year and we used
that to acquire all the royalties we
went to the guy that owned the royalty
we said we'll give you a million of
stock and a million of cash to buy the
royalty now we have two now we have four
now we have 25 now we have 50. now we
have 70 okay so we have like hundreds of
thousands of ounces of gold in the
ground spread all over the world that
someone else is going to dig up and the
actual investor could have done could
have been with us the whole way i bought
the stock in the market like as a
director you can you can see that so i
know how to make money in this zone and
so my thing with crypto is it's like i
don't really need
to go and
have a thumb drive with you know 20
bitcoin on it just to be in it i don't i
just a lot of people that would disagree
with you on that because to me uh of
for example like the whole storage thing
i think that's a lot that's going to be
a big argument that they're going to
have palms going to have on the side
uh the argument of direct fight of
crypto versus gold i think crypto is
going to win i don't think gold is a
direct fight
against i think gold is a fight against
fiat i think gold is a fight against
that if you ever fight directly with
bitcoin you're gonna get your tail
handed to you because their argument is
a better argument and i'm not a crypto
guy or a gold guy i'm simply a business
guy is what i am i'm talking from a very
logical reasonable uh side myself so but
let me go back i asked you a question
and very quickly you you kind of said no
to it you don't think meta is the future
so you don't think what zucker just did
the fact that the next generation of 12
year olds today 18 year olds today are
going to be sitting there hours a day
instead of being on their phone they're
going to be on their virtual reality in
a meta world you don't think that's the
direction we're going metaverse medical
you said metal is the thing no no no no
no metaverse
definitely metaverse is where people are
going to live i mean and and this is
where people are going to exist and
interact i mean you know like right
roblox i mean there's very little it's
all over again it's very interesting and
you they'll tell you i need some some of
this to buy a uh digital watch
yeah in the so that i can have i can
flex with my watch in the metaverse and
you're thinking hang on a minute uh tell
me that one more time dylan showed it to
me they said that can i show me can i
get 10 bucks to buy this i'm like to do
what yeah and so and so
can you can you zoom out and see
where this is going i mean i predict by
the end of the decade this is so
pervasive that people want to take a
psychedelic to have a human experience
this is going to be you know the drugs
have remember the 80s is like the coke
era and then the 90s is like you have
these eras right and so people are going
to crave that type of
we're human beings we're humans like you
can't get away from it so remember right
now your kid at 10 years old mask okay
they're going to school that no one can
see their face you better wash your
hands all the time don't play with any
other kids stay home stay in your room
and what's happening i'm anxious kids
are having like all these problems like
i'm anxious i don't know what to do i
can't talk to anyone the kids can't talk
i mean i'm pat i'm sure your kids can
then you go home you go online you can
talk because because you you're you you
have this type of engagement with your
family but it's like the average kid in
a dr horton home and a subdivision
that's locked in his room covered in
sanitizer he's up there metaverse is his
is his one
and so what where is this headed is you
can see a society that goes down this
type of path and imagine from the
controlling elite you're now you're all
your your whole life is infinitely
controllable because you've you've
abandoned all your critical thinking
skills i mean all einstein like carl
sagan all these guys said you know the
the technology evolves to the point
where people abandon the ability to
think and to be human and to have
critical so did ted cruz
critical thought you know and you can
see this happening right now i mean i i
i'm like you i go somewhere and i'm like
how you doing and people are absolutely
terrified i mean
and that's a new concept this is not
that that didn't exist before because
early yeah yeah but this wait wait so i
mean i agree with you 100 and i i think
society is going to really break into
like two different realms there you're
going to have the the the real and the
and the pseudo real the virtual in the
real world yeah so that but that
actually goes against your art exactly i
mean the idea of his kids are going to
interact with digital currency far more
in their life than they're ever going to
interact with
will there ever ever be a time where
people say holy crap my entire existence
is controllable
yeah i don't know can you pull that back
please i don't know the books people can
see will there be will there will there
ever be a point where
there's no there's maybe is though will
they care because i mean if you told me
two years ago that the city of new york
and the people inside
would allow somebody to shut their
businesses down would allow somebody to
curfew them and muzzle them would allow
somebody to essentially put soft martial
lawn on the city of new york for years i
would say you're out of your mind and
he'll be people hanging from the bridge
and it didn't happen
they agreed with yeah and what's amazing
is you ask them what makes new york
great they're like capitalist center of
the world and you're like really there's
a question though it's crazy here's a
question though yeah man what's new guys
what do what are we like but what this
is what's new i can i can actually
answer that because i've thought about
this stop what's new is that
the control is now comfortable
when our forefathers got taxed and they
didn't have representation they were
there was discomfort there wasn't
constant distraction right now you can
be controlled your life is controlled
but you're in an air-conditioned room
you have access to a metaverse i don't
know you have distractions today
push back let me push back okay what
happened in 1913
what happened in 1913 1930 got an income
tax taxes were introduced of course okay
but only for the millionaires dude
there's five of them fine but but here's
the question okay let me let me go to a
different timeline for you and then they
what happened they didn't like it so
they created
their money what happened in 1862 1863
1862 where it was a civil war was okay
and then lincoln came out and he said
we need to have taxes because we need to
pay off the civil war
once we pay it off we will get away with
taxes right sure and the american people
said what okay we trust you bro
okay fine i'll pay some taxes so he put
some tears it was by the way was minimal
like two to six percent six to ten
percent and he says once we pay off the
debt for civil war we'll stop paying
taxes but you know what happened to
taxes do you think it ever went away
never go away here's the thing it did go
away in 1872 under lincoln in 1872
income taxes went away okay but let me
explain to where i'm going with this 13.
cigar taxes didn't go away i mean the
income tax that they had
which was the main one that collected
most of the money so that went away
which was the model guys listen like
imagine if i come up and i say guys
we just raised 50 million dollars to do
this
look here's what we got with the movie
it's gonna blow up i need you guys to
take a 10 pay cut and your income i'll
take 100 pay cut you guys in i hope you
do it and we say okay let's do it and
then but at the time same time if we
come back we'll increase the 15
the point is for the longest time people
have said
all right cool
withholding tax that you know the whole
withholding tax withholding concept you
know who came up with that a guy named
milton friedman and he said it was one
of the biggest regrets i make in my life
that i agreed to it what i'm trying to
say is historically we've all been like
majority of the world's been like okay
there's been a select few of ten percent
of people that are willing to fight back
to bully the bully and everybody else
had to make a decision to see who was
better at presenting their argument but
the point i'm trying to make here with
them on the meta side and i want you to
push back on this as well on the meta
side is the following
if we are going that direction
there's nothing you can do about it on
the meta side to change it we can't
change that direction we're going in
that direction it is already too late a
guy pitched a meta world for
valuetainment to me
three years ago antonio who was here
with us and i'm like what and then now
he came back and now we're having a real
conversation about it so if we go to
that route
this means what sure yes this is
well you'll just buy a representation of
that in the valuetainment world
you know you'll have like a gold mine
that has little trucks moving but that
becomes an nfl
they're selling digital real estate now
there's digital land that doesn't
someone just bought a multi-million
dollar yacht on a megaverse
it's hanging out on a fake yeah i'd
rather go to a real yacht
will there ever be a time where
maybe you're taking the mushroom trip to
have a human experience and you say sure
wait a minute like i had a thought and
my social credit score went down and now
i don't have access to the valuetainment
metaverse because i'm being punished
they're trying will it ever happen and
what will you want in security you're
trying to create an environment of
insulated insecurity you're fat on a
real yacht you're not fat on the
metaverse shot you're short in real life
you're not short in metaverse you can't
dunk in real life but on nba on an nba
2k you can dunk you can 360. so there's
this idea that that the real world is
unfair so now going back to your point
these people are able to get control
because they're making life fairer for
everybody give up all my control in the
real world because i don't like the real
world i don't like who i am i don't like
the money that i make i don't like the
way that i look juxtaposed against this
i don't like the girlfriend that i have
the metaverse is the world that i want
this is my idealized version of self
so i will give up everything in the real
world and as long as you keep me safe
and as long as i can have access to my
id like
let me go somewhere with that let me go
somewhere with that that just happened
you guys saw mark cuban bought a small
small city right yeah what did he pay
for by the he was like four million
dollars okay let me let me read that
real quick and you'll see where i'm
going with this king texas yeah
something like that he just decided to
buy this city mark cuban buys a small
town in texas just because cnn he just
bought the entire town of mustang texas
a blip on the map off i-45 with a
population of 21 people the reason cuban
said a body needed to sell it i don't
know what if anything i will do with it
cuban said mustang is pretty much a
77-acre blank canvas for cuban the town
was founded in the 1970s and etcetera
said there's nothing really crazy about
it right on why he bought this for four
million bucks but here's what i will
tell you
to argue my own point i just made to
argue my own point i just made this the
following here's what i think
folks who have money ought to do here's
what i think folks who have money ought
to do
i think i think what would be very
interesting is the following america was
kind of founded on being a
country that you would come to that you
had to qualify to come here right you
went through what the whole uh
the island you would go to rikers
not rikers
alice you'd go to ellis island and the
first question was what what value do
you bring to us yeah and you would say i
know how to sew i know how to do this i
know and i would say okay cool come on
here you're bringing value to america
right that was the right setup and then
it was what
what value do you bring who cares come
on you're a criminal totally fine bro
come on it's okay we welcome everybody
it's standards were dropped it's almost
like this img whatever the sports
program is they pay eighty-three
thousand
where you go then your kid goes becomes
one of the best tennis players and they
said you know what you're rich pat send
your kid it's okay you're low on the
standard just because of money right
that's what happened to america it
dropped the standards dramatically what
i would be very interested in is the
following take some of these guys like a
uh uh who's the guy that made five
billion dollars on a roth ira peter
thiel take some of these guys who bring
their money together and they say look
let's put a hundred billion dollars
let's buy a small country and the only
people that can come here you have to
qualify and the standards are so high
and in our constitution it states you
have to only bring value to come here
who is john galt who but but i think
that's the direction
it's coming next if you get to the
tipping point that you piss off the
creators the creators always have an
option so what i'm saying to you is i
think this whole thing of majority
saying oh my gosh the government is so
good to me they're giving me so many
free things this is awesome what a great
noble of people i can just stay at home
and kick in and just buy ethereum and
bitcoin and make money and play video
games these guys are the greatest people
i've ever seen in my life and they're
gonna say oh really really no problem
you want to do drugs did you hear what
elon musk said yesterday in an interview
about drugs did you guys hear about this
or no elon musk says drugs probably make
you age more if you can go a little bit
lower tesla elon musk was spoke out in
opposition to president joe biden's
economic signature question need for
legislation that would support electric
car
adoption due to concerns government and
then he's talking and then eventually he
starts talking about drugs in this
interview so yes we're going in this
direction
of hey you should try this you know try
this drug try that drug try this truck i
think the creators
in the next 5 10 15 years what mark
cuban did with four million bucks dude
if a hundred billion dollars people say
we're buying a country you want in it's
10 million dollars behind no problem i'm
in
i'm fully in put 10 million dollars to
minimum 10 million buying to live in
this place let's go create and then we
go and then we start building our own
country i think do not be surprised if
in the next five 10 15 years that takes
place well it's called singapore and it
already exists and yeah yeah it was
exactly this concept yeah that's where
everyone is by the way there's been more
family offices open there than any other
place in the world medical bills
bloomberg new economy forum is by the
way that's the next generation of world
economic forum that's kind of done it's
the bloomberg new economy forum it just
happened it was in singapore everybody
was there you know there's too many jets
and not enough hangers i mean it's this
type of thing is going on yeah but have
you seen what singapore looks like by
the way can you pull up singapore
it used to be a swamp okay so so but but
this is you're talking about something
that's different from
uh imagine that as a swamp to that you
know all because of what you're talking
about but in this era the the power okay
the power is in in control of data
i mean data is what these guys want to
control like musk the cars are not the
issue here you know it's control it's
it's what can you grab that's where your
power comes from but we're talking about
the underclass you know in america there
was no nowadays it's like you just walk
across the border and get a social
security number and you're part of the
underclass and elites love a huge
underclass it's kind of like when you go
to mexico city it's it's a it's a nice
place if you're an elite because you
have a big wall around your place and
you have guards you have all these
things and it's not a nice place if
you're looking for meritocracy for a
place to to rise feudalism it's very
difficult but if you're at the top it's
nobody is going to come and get you as
long as you play your cards libra is
good for the plantation owner exactly
and so what you're talking about is is
very complicated because you have this
gigantic underclass that's kind of
waiting for the sweepstakes with crypto
you know the next coin that went up to a
penny is pancake coin you know and
everybody's like oh my friend had it i
should have bought it i mean this is
distraction and metaverse is distraction
but now you're talking about elite what
elites are going to do and they're not
going to advertise that you can come to
the compound i mean these guys are doing
this it's happening right now i mean
these guys are not sitting around in
kansas city in a subdivision i mean it's
it's it's i i will tell you there is a
way to
uh uh there is a way to
uh judge somebody that's gonna bring
that even is a not a millionaire not a
billionaire that's gonna bring value to
your town it's very easy to con to
decipher and process through that's not
that complicated what are you bringing
to the table we're going away from what
are you bringing to the table so this is
a two-point argument here that we the
last 15 minutes we went into we'll
change the topic here in a second one of
the arguments is is meta coming
yes is it going away i don't think so
you may say it's going to i don't think
it's going away if it's not going away
this is uh uh not going to be
the same as it's been in the last 20
years because meta is a full argument
against this and nft ethereum bitcoin
all of that is going to be an argument
for
why you ought to be there because if you
want to buy a token the only we can buy
token 50 of the time is through ethereum
right right if you want to get in there
if you want to buy an nft if you want to
do this you know i was just at art basel
conference this last week you guys went
to the art pass so you know how it was
so
you're walking around and you're looking
at greensboro north carolina well you
crushed it i mean i you know some of the
guys were sending me messages but uh
but going back to it so i was at art
basel and i'm walking i'm looking out
these pictures okay some of the stuff
was freaking strange that's art i love
it right
but
i don't know if you saw that there was
like 10 galleries that were selling nft
art
and that's all it was did you talk to
perez you know there was a he had
comments that that went
kind of george yeah i mean it went he
got like a lot of heat because
he was really upset about this because
he said art is an experience you know
it's kind of like i've been out to
martha texas to see the donald judd
foundation and it's really a trip
everyone should should make i mean jeff
gunlock is the one that told me about
visiting there he's like you got to
visit there it's this dan flavin light
exhibits and all these things you can't
see them anywhere else see them anywhere
else okay think about what gunlock told
me you can't see them anywhere else you
go to the judd foundation no cameras not
because they don't want you to
photograph the art because donald judd
said if you're looking at the aperture
of a camera you're not using your eyes
and the art affects your eyes because
you look at the art you have an
experience and i want you to have that
experience here you can look at your
camera some other time
perez is saying that he's saying art is
an experience how old is perez perez
not young
but but he i mean there you go i know
the argument so here's the thing are we
transitioning into a time where the
experience is you've got a rock with two
laser eyes and you flex in the metaverse
and if we are then what you're saying is
human beings now are comfortable
not having individuality which probably
is true but will they ever wake up and
say
my whole entire life is
captured and gone well there's two
different arguments that are being made
right here well do you do do you
eventually most people become grumpy old
men okay slowly
and and by the way and we have to
uh uh cling on whatever our legacy is
and anything that takes away from our
legacy
we kind of become grumpy so let's just
say whatever that like if you're like do
you know anything about george perez do
you know what pam
it's the perez art museum of miami i
lived across the street from it so like
the guy has a vested interest in typical
art what i'm trying to say is what i'm
trying to say is if you're going there
and the legacy is tied to it he has to
say that yeah but unfortunately i don't
own a single nft not one i don't know
one of those monkeys any and i don't
know none of that stuff right on the
board apes
the apes i don't know if i may
eventually buy one i'm telling you guys
if right now i don't all i'm saying to
you is
a comment like that being made
you know goes back to the movie grumpy
old man let me say something against the
guy he's a legend i get it but in that
market the argument from nft is going to
be yeah let me say something about what
eb said that i want to revisit and you
touch on it with the nft so you talked
about essentially the warren buffett
quote about be fearful when people are
greedy grief greedy when people are
fearful
i was also there a few hours after you
this was what was something i was there
when my wife and kids you were there
with four girlfriends
regardless we were checking out art it
was good adrian actually bought a piece
adrian bought a piece in crypto buddy a
real piece uh
but you used digital currency to buy a
real piece of art jackpot right so
here's my point be fearful when people
are greedy so we're there we're checking
out art it's crazy it's expensive we
usually hot tip you go on sunday yeah at
seven o'clock when it ends at eight
and they're selling a piece for five
that money you go for they're selling a
piece for five grand you're like look
it's gonna cost you a thousand bucks to
ship it i'll take it off your hand i'll
give you for 3200 bing bing bing bang
bang bang so some guy comes up to me and
he has this like french accent he's like
yes they're good look at this piece it's
we're selling it as an nft and uh you
have to understand that we're we're
showing you the experience but then when
you buy it so and i go yeah but you know
what so what's the nfts like yes this is
the wave of the future and you have to
understand and i go yeah but but what's
the nft and like
maybe perez owns the building
we get to the bottom of it finally all
right almost back yeah i'm buddies with
his son jp perez
total panel
so anyways you were saying so the old
the book that kid yeah it's bad there's
a children's book the emperor's clothes
you know and we all know the story is
that the they're like no no you look
great you should spend a lot of your
treasure to buy this new fabric and
there is no fabric and he's naked he's
naked and he's then he's all embarrassed
in the end and so what what we're really
saying is will there ever be a moment
when people say
holy crap i mean i actually need
something
that i can put my hand on and the answer
so far has been no so
not for one year or two years
tesla back in the day was saying that he
didn't like the concept of television
because people will think they've gone
to the grand canyon because they've seen
the grand canyon you haven't really seen
the grand canyon you know and it's you
know his whole thing was he wanted to
transport people there that's what he
think technology should have been used
for you know human transport instead of
just you know he thought it was
cheapening like you know obviously
edison didn't get along but he thought
it was cheap that somebody could take a
digital rendering of something show it
to somebody and then their brain would
interpret it as having been there you
know but
we're going to be able to go
to the grand canyon in the metaverse
we're going to be able to go who wants
to stand in line in disney world you can
go into disney world in the metaverse
and not have a line and then go up and
down the roller coaster in the metaverse
and i
philosophically i tend to agree with you
i don't like where it's going i think
it's dangerous i think that giving up
personal autonomy for non-stop uh you
know serotonin is stimulating horrible
yeah uh but i i don't know why is it
horrible
because now someone can turn it off yeah
it's total control you right that's
that's even see all we're talking about
is the upside of it the smartphone's
great you know where you're going all
the time you can pre-order a coffee and
make it any way you want you know but
someone can turn it off no no see this
you're saying that controller can turn
out
but
as a user you can also turn it off let's
say i'm going off the grid real quick
this is what i think has happened in
this conversation this is what i've
we're having two different conversations
at the same time we're having a
conversation about where this thing is
going
and then you're having a conversation
about why it's wrong to go that way i
don't disagree with you but we're
talking about trying to speculate we're
talking about tangible yeah and real you
can do both i i really believe you can
do both i mean that's why i talk about
the platform of the crypto and then the
coins if you understand the platform and
you understand the coins and you want to
make a play into it knowing that you can
do both you can do both but you're going
to do you can choose i think you're but
you're not getting i'm i'm i've kind of
got all that i need you're all in on
gold yeah it's not i'm not all in on
gold i mean i have the carbon credit
royalty is incredible you know i mean
you're planting mangrove trees you know
in southeast asia and selling the the
the carbon capture to people that fly an
airplane but like right there though but
you're doing carbon credits carbon
credits is basically a tax for living
it's an existence tax it's just so
everything is carbon so i mean how can
you you're you're worried about yeah you
know the
the morality of one thing and then the
other one i'm not worried about the
morality like i think you can you can
play a trend you know and then you can
do something with your own
money i don't think there's anything
more evil and i know that all the
environmentalists and the lefts and they
think i'm a crazy righty and all that
stuff there's nothing more evil in the
world to me than a carbon tax who the
hell gets to tax you for living it's
crazy and people are all for it i mean
take a poll of young people and they say
that's important i mean people are more
interested in that business by the way
than this than the metalla metallo
business you tell someone about 30 years
of gold no i'm not interested 30 years
of mangrove trees i'm all in i want that
when can i buy that on robin hood i'm
ready right now it's amazing investment
bankers like we'll we'll do a road show
for that we're going public next
next fall they'll set up two weeks of
meetings in the gold business one day
i i i uh um
i don't know you know i'm not uh
you will never put me in the box of a
crypto guy would you ever put me you've
been with me for how many no you're not
a crypto guy and i'm not a gold guy but
i own both you are a card guy you're a
baseball card guy by the way i own uh
most for me is cards
uh second most would be probably crypto
then it's gold is what i own okay but my
number one is cards and i'm not
including my investments obviously
that's number one stocks all the other
stuff that's equities is number one but
then number two is this and
and so
for me when i think about this
this is
you know it's it's a different it's a
different gig
i think this
i don't think this is gonna the only
thing that this is gonna it's gonna make
this explode is a catastrophic event so
if you think about the triggers
inflation goes up this needs to go up it
didn't work
a a level of uncertainty in the world a
war happens
a a massive you know pandemic happens
this needs to go up
it didn't really work like that so the
triggers have changed in a major way you
know there's speculation in stocks there
is the fed all of a sudden votes
somebody in that's a communist from
russia and she replaces let's just say
powell oh we got to be careful because
we don't know what she's going to do
okay that goes up
but it hasn't so so many things isn't
moving this and so many things are
moving crypto bitcoin ethereum that they
can say c
c c yeah and gold can't say c c c so the
credibility for the gold community in my
opinion has gone down that's yeah it has
and so here here's here's the thing when
you get back to that thing about the
moody family right
you want to buy your hedge when it's
cheap
like everybody wants to buy insurance
the day after the hurricane comes
through right it's really expensive
right and there hasn't been a storm for
years no one wants to buy insurance
that's when you buy the insurance so to
take a one percent hedge right now to
your point is extraordinarily cheap it's
never been cheaper because you have all
the signs of swirling you know clouds in
the air and people are like no i don't
want that so so take the hedge when it's
cheap and then also play
the speculative move like play that move
that's a you're basically saying in
sports you don't just play offense you
don't just play defense you gotta play
both sides of the ball so play some d
and then get on your own nobody cares
and so you you can get in there the
ironic part about what you're saying
also man is like nobody clamors for
freedom until they have none of it yeah
nobody clamors for for an open society
until they're complete well then let's
go to the bad guys are winning let's
talk about the bad guys are winning this
is an atlantic story which is kind of
surprising that they're writing this
today's great article yeah today the
most brutal members of autocracy inc
don't much care if their countries are
criticized or by whom the leaders of
iran confidently discount the views of
western infidels the leaders of cuba and
venezuela dismiss the statement of
foreigners on the grounds that they are
imperialist the leaders of china have
spent a decade disputing the human
rights language long used by
international institutions successfully
convincing many people around the world
that these western concepts don't apply
to them russia has gone beyond merely
ignoring foreign criticism to outright
mocking it if america removes the
promotion of democracy from its foreign
policy if america ceases to interest
itself in the fate of other democracies
and democratic movements then
autocracies will quickly take our place
as source of influence funding and ideas
if americans together with our allies
fail to fight the habits and practices
of autocracy abroad we will encounter
them at home indeed they are already
here if americans don't help to hold
murderous regimes to account those
regimes will retain their sense of
impunity they will continue to steal
blackmail torture intimidate inside
their countries as well as inside ours
thoughts yeah look the the title says it
all the bad guys are winning so
by default
we have to remember here that in america
we're the freaking good guys
we're the people that the world needs
and it's so easy you know like the trump
interview it's like oh you think we're
so good you don't think we've done
something yeah okay i got that part
right we've not not every we're not not
everything we do is the best thing ever
but without america as the number one
power in the world who takes over china
that's who's that's who we're going to
leave the power of the world in and look
at what they've mentioned in this
article look at the names iran cuba
north korea venezuela china those are
the bad guys those those are the
autocrats something that we need to
um understand we're obviously a
capitalist channel and entrepreneurship
but above that
is democracy there's only one way to do
it though there's only one way to do it
let me explain to what i mean by this so
last week we had a meeting in dallas i'm
back to dallas again tomorrow morning
and then i'm back again so i've been
december and january february for me
such a busy season it's great by the way
we just closed on a new building
yesterday which is exciting for
valuetainment but let me tell you what
happened when i was in dallas i'm in
dallas last week we have a meeting
it's a day and a half we start early we
go late
it was the most emotionally intense
meeting we've ever held there's not a
single person that wasn't upset in the
room and there was a single person that
didn't cry in the room very emotional
with the vision what we want to do next
with our company okay
let me tell you what happened
yesterday jose marlene gaitan their
organization their agency that they run
they do around 30 40 million a year
their organization yesterday had an
explosive day on a monday you don't have
explosive days on mondays okay
the language they're speaking is insane
people who disagreed with each other are
now on the same page people who didn't
want to be in the same room together are
now let's go kill the enemy right
the problem with america on this
article that they write by
freaking atlantic there's 95 other
articles by atlantic that does the
complete opposite of this you
write one article talking about we're so
great you write 94 other articles about
how america is this it's on you the
media so for me rather than saying
something like this why don't we unite
on the common enemy that we have who is
the common enemy
you don't see a common enemy today you
see aoc on one side mentioned on the
other side trump's the enemy in america
the enemy is the opposite political
party that's the biggest problem but but
that's caused by the atlantic being part
of the mainstream it's not just that i'm
not saying my enemy is our power
the point i'm trying to make with the
media is as much as the media wants to
write noble articles like this how about
we hold you accountable for having
caused this division in america today
how about we hold you to the fire for
all this you do with journalism
that you have to be held accountable for
you given actual journalistic integrity
you ain't got no journalistic integrity
so you write one article you think
you're all noble now you want to go out
there and talk about this no i think the
problem in america is here today look at
this
china threatens u.s over expected
diplomatic boycott china will take
firm counter measures let me read this
article to you and see where i'm going
with this part here
so uh uh uh the daily wire the biden
administration is expected to announce
this week that no u.s government
official will attend the 2022 beijing
olympics implementing the diplomatic
boycott of the game cnn reported the
move would allow the u.s to send a
message to the world stage to china
without preventing u.s athletes from
competing foreign minister spokespers
ministry spokesperson mock the us over
the expected move claiming that they
were never invited anyway but then later
making it a threat without being invited
american politicians keep hyping the
so-called diplomatic boycott or debating
winter olympics which is purely wishful
thinking and grandstanding he said if
the u.s site is bent on going its own
way channel will counter measures take
firm counter measures senator ted cruz
told cbs news last month that he
supported the diplomatic boycott of the
2022 winner olympics in beijing and u.s
athletes needed to go over to kick their
commies ass right so okay we need stuff
like that
we need a true enemy today to unite the
hell out of america but everybody needs
to be on the same page so for me you
write an article like that great people
like us talk about under podcast people
share with other people but at the end
of the day one article one piece no
america is pretty united right now
because people are pinning people
against each other the whole cuomo
scandal that took place okay
with whatever happened with his brother
that's going back and forth and it
happens to him and they found that he
was getting guys on the inside to work
with him then
he suppressed the information he's
against but here's the kicker though on
what happened the kicker is all of that
stuff that happened he came out and said
i'm sorry zucker knew and he was helping
out as well what are we talking about
here and then he's going to cnn saying
you better pay me my 18 million or
whatever the number that's left so look
at the debacle of this you know cnn that
was a god agency you know a media
company a year ago two years ago now
everybody's like wait what now don lemon
i don't know if you saw don lemon what
came out this morning about don lemon
did you guys hear about don lemon's
house don lemon was doing the same thing
to what what chris did to andrew don was
doing to just see smallest okay so this
whole thing can break down very quickly
there's more and there's more but the
point i'm trying to make is the first
way
we become united
is when media
is held okay
if you went to school to columbia
university to become this wonderful
journalist that you are and you're
superior to us because you got this yell
thing going on or this whatever thing
going on brown thing going on and we
went to glendale community college or
whatever university and college we went
to i'm sorry now it's on you rather than
bullying all of america and dividing
them how about you get held accountable
a little bit and then let's see how you
guys respond but aren't they being held
accountable their ratings are going down
and down and down america's waking up
they're listening to them more and more
people
cnn is used as a derogatory term now
online it's like oh you must watch cnn
if you think that so i think in a
certain way the market is talking the
market the information market is
speaking and i mean you made a lot of
great points about but i will i will
disagree man i think the atlantic
having that article is a step in the
right direction i agree the people that
listen to the atlantic have never felt
that there's there is a however though
there's a big however though
if you do it one time
just like let me give you an example
what i mean by this you know how
sometimes uh a cnn will do an article to
kind of get the republicans to be like
oh i agree you know so then they bring
membership in or like uh some of these
guys like bill maher did it one time and
republicans are like i agree with bill
finally yeah
but bill mars continues 95 year and a
half so if atlantic goes and stays in
the middle and actually reports good for
you you make money you deserve to make
money but if they do this one hit piece
to get attention there yeah even if pat
it's a step in the right direction
because those there's a we both know
when it's on both sides that
you could say something but if they
don't hear it from their side they don't
believe it it's not what you say is who
says it is what you're talking so
there's there we are not living in a in
a simultaneous reality we're living in
two different realities based on
ideology and then even if for one second
there's a crossover that's a step in the
right direction yes for one second that
they say hey look there's an autonomous
regime that has the quote-unquote global
cabal that everybody keeps making fun of
no no it exists that it's real and these
guys want to take over
that's a good that's a step in the right
direction that's a step forward i don't
disagree by the way yeah i'm totally
with you however the only thing i would
say is let's see how they follow up the
next month the next three months six
months 12 months
if they go in that direction then go
think about it from this angle okay
think about it from this angle think
about what happened with forbes
i've been a die-hard forbes guy for 20
years go read a forbes article today
it's like wait a minute
you know you know it's chinese-owned 95
percent
i know 95 so you think
you're reading about the great ideas of
capitalism i don't touch forbes i don't
touch 90 of these business magazines
because it's ran by journalists who hate
capitalism yeah yeah so if these guys go
back to certain set of values like let's
just say atlantic says hey folks
let's have a meeting yeah okay let's
just say this is caused by a meeting
that was held you guys had to stand up
you know meeting yesterday right on
monday let's say there's a meeting and
they say
somebody comes out and says guys let's
unify what's the greatest country in the
world well i i i don't know if we can
speculate that you did
dan mark you you got you know this and
you got sweden all this no no
no listen let's not get it twisted
america's the greatest country in the
world i love that video you did in your
car by the way which one about if
america was a restaurant
if america was a that's right everybody
wants to come yeah yeah so so what i'm
saying to you is if that kind of a
meeting took place with somebody at
atlantic oh we need more of those well
there's two things that happened also in
the last half hour and actually really
just happened at this table that i
really hope the audience understands
you're talking about narrative all right
and you're talking about common enemy
and the power of a common enemy and the
power of a narrative the narrative
forever has been in our media that the
common enemy in america is america and
it's our past towards the other side no
it's our past no justice on stolen land
how many times have you heard there can
be no justice on stolen land as if every
land every nation ever created wasn't
created through some sort of warfare as
if
even the native americans themselves
didn't shade borders based on
inter-tribal warfare this was always
lenape land they never fought against
the cherokee are you nuts right conflict
over resources was the entire source of
evolution genghis khan mongolia what are
we talking about here like i ran all
over the world every single nation has
been founded through conflict and
acquisition so we're not the only
country so this idea that every american
1612 project whatever yeah the idea that
everything that's ever happened in this
country is by its its very good point
illegitimate it's nonsense yeah on its
base point yeah and unless we have
somebody from that side point that out
yeah that narrative is going to be
pervasive like that is freaking to you
that that narrative is not coming from
america you know what it's like but
bring it down to the average person
right bring it down to the average
person so let's just say
uh uh uh he and i are brothers
hypothetically we're brothers and we're
two years apart okay we grew up we're
best friends of course we fought we've
done all that other stuff but if i cling
on what he did at 16 years old when he
took my video game away and i keep
reminding them that 42 years old well
listen man you screwed up as well let's
chill out everybody here makes mistakes
so there is a community it's even worse
than that pat it's
somebody who looked like him stole your
phone 16 years and you blame him and
you're holding him accountable yeah no
question about it that you you make a
very good point or somebody's great
great great great great great
grandfather that looked like him yeah
that did it exactly not the six-year-old
character
you shouldn't trust
the guy i sat down with lucian you're
your best friend can you pull up the
interview illusion trust god for people
to see the first 30 seconds
i sit down with this guy he's the great
great grandson of thomas jefferson he's
a writer he's won all these awards all
over the place he agreed to do an
interview with me which i couldn't
believe he agreed to do the interview
because he he's on the complete chaplain
lucian trust god bet david yeah the
third right there go trust god i just
spelled it for you in a valley team look
the first one pops up okay type that and
then see how this thing goes because he
starts bitching about thomas jefferson
and uh uh uh the is that is the internet
just going real slow
okay
being
what you're talking about a grandfather
sixth generation passed on what he did
and they're sitting there saying because
of that we need to remove his statue put
a different place that's the first
grandson wanted his stature removed this
guy is the great great great great
grandson of thomas jefferson if you want
to make that bigger and hopefully like
the entire reason that we're talking
raise audio race audio and go back can
you
do we have audio or no
david
do we have audio
press play
[Laughter]
can you press play on the bottom left
even when you press it doesn't do
anything
okay we'll wait for this to come up so
yeah i agree this this this goes back to
the constant past of but you understand
we're not the do you know why pat it's
playing but there's no audio there
because the past can't defend itself
they keep going after the past because
the past can't defend itself it's an
easy target you find something wrong
some there's nobody that would ever
defend slavery ever nobody in their
right mind would defend slavery so you
take somebody who did something
egregious and you attack them and they
can't defend themselves but but here's
the part here's here's what i think
needs to happen with that okay i think
those people that are trying to defend
themselves need to take a different
angle i'll give you an idea
okay if you want to go back and play
let's just go back a few
thomas jefferson may have written the
words all men are created equal but he
really didn't do very much in his life
to make that happen you're saying to
tear down jefferson and replace it with
harriet tubman i didn't say that don't
put words in my mouth who would you say
the best president we've had in the last
hundred years are you serious i love
this country and it changed my life and
i'm asking you these are ridiculous
questions this is sitting here you asked
you can't answer that can you yeah i did
say it what is it ask the guy you're in
the studio with i asked what i'm
interviewing you not them i didn't ask
you why you think anything i know who
wrote the declaration of independence i
don't disagree with you on a lot of
things i'm an immigrant so am i were you
born here no i wasn't i don't answer
questions like this
questions asking me who's my favorite
because your favorite president said
thomas jefferson represents what's best
in america that's why what a
you know you know he said you know the
whole time i had a quote of all the
presidents what good they said about
jefferson i said who's your favorite
president says barack obama i said
that's what barack obama said about
jefferson so the guy that's your
greatest president agrees that jefferson
needs to stay there this is what makes
this beautiful country look ugly when a
guy like this who's
been able to leverage a last name like
then i got a job in journalism because
he's a jefferson guy and he bashes the
guy that gave him that privilege sir if
you're him and you have his philosophy
it's kind of like the both thing you
could say yes you know he's my my
great-great-grandfather was a founder of
this country he's the one of the
greatest people to ever live in america
yet yes he did some wrongs and yes that
we could we could address that we're not
going to sweep that under the rug but
like make you know make no mistake when
people
call you names what happens is they've
abandoned the intellectual argument do
you notice that like when they you can
see them abandoning abandoning them well
you're a nasty you're not an
yeah i mean it's like it's nonsense i
mean it's you i love when people do that
because immediately it's over you just
you know we're no longer talking
now we're just having a street brawl by
the way did you see what trump said did
you guys see here about what trump said
the other day
can you play that video right there this
is adam's favorite story adam i don't
want to go today without having the
story because i know you really like the
story so let me read to you guys what
happened so
uh uh uh uh i know trump claims he
doesn't drink but he sounded even more
like a drunk uncle at a wedding tonight
than usual
here he calls general milly an f an
idiot who's whose tweet is that by the
way who's that by
that you put the tweet by i'm trying
this oh this is the guy ron whoever it
is okay make this bigger
and let's play this here's what trump
said watch this
[Music]
you mean you think it's cheaper
to leave it there
so they can have it than it is to fill
it up with a half a tank of gas and fly
it into pakistan afghanistan
yes sir we think it's cheaper sir
that's when i realized he was a
idiot
[Applause]
he doesn't need to be president again he
needs his own show he needs a show by
the way go back you missed the first 10
seconds gold
9 million we have 60 70 million dollar
plans you mean you think it's cheaper
to leave it there so they can have it
than it is to fill it up with a half a
tank of gas and fly it into pakistan or
fly it back to what's good i mean they
heard a hole
so what do you think about what he said
there
i mean the comedy show the half a tank
of gas and you get it over to pakistan
it could have been a comedian well the
first part of the clip that is cut off
is he talks about we had just had brand
new 50 million dollar airplanes 26
million dollar helicopter yeah i'll i'll
get i'll make this quick point and we go
the biggest problem with trump
is the policy versus the persona he's
absolutely freaking right about the
policy we've left
billions and billions of uh of
armory and everything than planes and
helicopters and everything for our enemy
he has an absolute credible point there
and then the persona the
like that's where he loses the biggest
problem with the voter is uh they see
emotion more than they see logic so the
same problem is is on the other end as
well when it comes to well it's the same
problem with that we have with gold the
biggest problem with the average
american is i'd rather have the cash and
the gold when you know
because they'd rather have the picture
of the rock with the laser eyes
exactly sometimes
do you miss him because think about it
we don't know where biden is we never
see him there's no prescription this guy
was always press conference
doesn't think we should have a pr anyone
uh over 70.
he would give a talk about something and
they would ask him about some other
unrelated thing he'd watch him like
defend it was kind of like a lot of
entertainment no we don't even see we
don't even have any presidency not just
him dude like you know jim acosta
thought he was an elected official
having a debate with uh with kelly
mckinney or what's her name
kellyanne collins
imagine caitlyn jacqueline oh god now
jen sackey comes out and says uh all the
rioting is because of the pandemic and
people were like oh press conferences
i mean if you were a press guy and that
was on white house duty imagine how
boring this is i mean you go in there
here's the notes for the day okay well
we just shared
back when he was in there it was like
attack mode you know all right we just
we just circulated a stat that biden
gets more negative uh press than trump
did no way no way no
that's not my freaking opinion that was
the stat that was going on i'm not
saying i'm not disagreeing with you i'm
just saying like i remember on the
bloomberg every single day it was just
like this goes back to gerard's point to
pat's point
right now the common and american
americans are the people across the
aisle from you that guy should be
it should be a china it should be these
authoritarian regimes but instead it's
either red or blue which side are you on
but this is what he did what he did is
he pulled the veil out from the elites
he's not talking about the the angry
parent at the the student conference
like
merrick garland's going after parents
who don't want their kids being taught
critical theory now they're on terrorist
watch list with the fbi true thing by
the way merrick garland google it he's
going after general milly everything he
ever did was establish a media general
milly elites elites elites elites so
that's why general millie is an elite
because he's a general yeah
general milia is an elite yeah i think
that that's pretty much i'm saying that
it's okay that's that's what a leader
has the guy i think i'm thinking i'm
thinking tech gazillion
maybe redefine swamp is more milly than
elite elite he's elite yeah but elite
in his eyes is much higher billionaires
of the world
without higher than one much higher
without knowing anything about
guarantees
you're saying access you're saying
powers on money so milly is is uh
curated curated bloodline i mean beyond
beyond zuckerberg zuckerberg is the top
pawn i mean you know it's we're talking
you know it's
you know curated bloodline go go on with
that no no that's for you know off off
the air but that's guys that have a lot
of money or something it's beyond money
it's power it's it's control it's not
the general you see these guys
occasionally just they're gone you know
i mean there's a new you know there's a
new guy is there one general that trump
actually gets along with now
mattis is out well look uh general
kelly's out
guys
millie's out why does trump not get
along with any u.s
questions that questions talk about
garland okay there's a great clip you
could find on youtube where hunter biden
paints pictures and and they're selling
i just bought an nft record record
prices higher than a picasso sketch was
sold and and they asked merrick garland
don't you see a problem with this and
he's like no i don't see any yeah
probably oh it's a big it's a big deal
anonymous buyer normal i support arts i
mean come on you know so you see this
thing i mean imagine if eric trump was
painting pictures and people were buying
them for a million dollars and he was
getting the money and this is all these
but look
you guys three billion dollar deals with
the ukraine for the big guys right all
these things that you're talking about
my hope for people back to your your
talk about them you're talking about
meritocracy you like this country
because you were able to know the rules
and get to work and use your creative
intellect and ability to to build
something okay so my hope for everybody
listening is that you can start writing
gigantic
income tax checks because that's when
the light switch goes off and your
thinking changes from being all
distracted about news stories and i know
all the people like i forbes i'm friends
with them okay up the road like i know
all these people and i know how stories
get produced and i know what when they
say zucker knew about i know the boom
that's not going on the the rag today
nice effort you're out of here i know
journalists make 50 grand and resent all
the people that they write about okay so
i know all this stuff but my hope is
when you're listening you can get
involved with your your pen okay writing
the check and saying what do they do
with all this money because your
thinking changes and it's not a
political thing but you start thinking
the way you're thinking of like wait a
minute this is the best restaurant you
know why i know this i've been to the
other restaurants you know and there's
rats in there and it's really bad you
know and this is why this is the best
and everything changes when you achieve
some success because your whole
perception it switches from all this
noise to what's real i i think that's a
great way to finish up we got two
minutes here very good point you just
made there go see what it feels like to
pay a lot of taxes and then you're going
to say what the hell am i paying the
taxes for and it's just as simple as i
remember one time jose andres god bless
you so one of my good friends great guy
with peruvian he would cook very good
for us on sundays uh he's in l.a and i'm
pitching him on texas and he comes to
texas we get in the car
and i go in a tollway the express lane
and it says three dollars and he says
wow we don't have this in california you
paid three dollars to go into slain i
said exactly i said here's how taxes
should work you pay taxes for what you
use i don't have to go on the express
lane but in california you have to pay
for taxes
i never use this is why i like taxes
like texas and just i never thought
about it that way before so it goes back
to pay a little tax and see what happens
by the way a couple things to wrap up
but this is exactly why for me when you
say
some people get pushed back and look oh
i don't know we have to apologize we
have to apologize we've had this
conversation many times before mafia
states americas has been a big kid do we
think this many thousands of people were
gonna order this in the first three four
days no we we had a number for the first
month and that was not the case uh it
was
record-breaking the commentary is
unfreaking believable here's just some
of the comments of people saying on
twitter on youtube on facebook all over
the place just this sit down alone was
gangster thanks to all what a tremendous
job patrick with the universities who
made the sirs uh maybe the best
interview of all time watching it all
over again it's amazing four episodes
and totally worth the wait well done pbd
congratu can you go to the next slide
because i wanted to be more about the
show the godfather just took a knee
there's a new boss in town mafia states
america will go down in history as one
the one the three greatest pieces of war
concerning the largest criminal
enterprise in the nation's history aside
from the government way to go
valuetainment bringing these two men
together and mayor in this fashion puts
to sleep every movie book podcast and
interview prior best of luck on your
next project
because this will be heart to top in
closing let's go
wow what an amazing sit down by george
cortez i would i could watch this a
million times over and never be tired of
it would love to see a second sin down
answering more questions mobber related
like jfk the mob live series etc etc
keep going to the next one uh uh uh this
beats hollywood anything out of
hollywood joseph c fuentes
likes uh holistic investing wow i knew
this was coming but you went the extra
mile amazing content as always great job
it's worth every penny uh mario's
certainness best way to spend 40 dollars
beautiful projects all the right
questions ask so many names shared to
confirm that both guys were a part of
the life at the time we were anyways
there's like hundreds of comments on
this and emails are coming left and
right and a bunch of people have already
binge watched and they're sending us
messages they can go to
mafiastatesamericalrightnow.com to order
the 10 episodes i will say one thing
that this made me think about
we talked to each other and we said if
we hit this many numbers of
subscribers to the show that watch it
we're gonna do our first feature film
right you know the number we've talked
about it right
the point i want to make to everybody
that's watching this if you
want to see somebody else get in the
marketplace to compete against
mainstream media support platforms like
this it doesn't have to be us if there's
somebody else that you see that's
willing to fight it go support him
support by buying a product subscribing
there's a lot of great platforms out
there as well but if you like what we're
doing with valuetainment you'd like to
see us doing a couple of feature films
with it's the heroes the capitalist the
heroes the entrepreneur the heroes any
of those stories that we take to the
next level uh we're excited for all of
you guys that have supported us from day
one but now we're kind of going to the
next part because now things cost money
you know what's funny people said well
your interview with sammy devil garvano
that got 13 million views that probably
made you half a million dollars so i'm
going to creative studios i don't think
people fully understand how you don't
have you don't have to know but let me
tell you what i want to show him okay
i'm going to creative studios right now
and i want to show this check this out
how much money you think sammy gravano's
interview
made i actually want you to guess
how much money
13 million
this is 13 million views from youtube i
want you to look at this okay what do
you think that's made
in its lifetime what do you think that's
made in its lifetime 100 grand how much
100 100 000 okay you ready here you go
since
published a hundred thousand dollars
you said 250 what do you think 13
million views has made 250 000
no clue
here's how much 13 million 96 000 views
has made
on sammy gravano can you say the number
am i looking at this that's like 11 500
that's lifetime 11
500 what is a sammy gravano interview 13
million dollars because youtube doesn't
pay adsense and half the stuff he talks
about so that's so that's before they
nerfed you so kids what pat's telling
you is if you want to be an influencer
when you grow up you better you know
save your money have a day job
anyways having said that uh very excited
for all the people that supported eb i
got to tell you i really enjoyed this
you being on uh great conversations
we're looking forward to having you back
on here one of these days i will tell
you when you are walking out with that
money make sure caroline's escorting you
out to be safe i don't think anyone
wants it i mean if i if i had a if i had
an nft maybe i'd be in trouble but with
this no problem by the way did you even
get the cash on the table or no did
people see the cash on everything that's
on the table for those of you guys that
are planning on having a big 2022 we are
doing a business workshop that will
happen december 20th it's a full day
event that i'll be hosting if you
haven't registered for that let's put
the link below as well in the comments
section for people to participate in
that also pat so people uh know in the
last instagram update so people that
don't know talking about you know access
to this and and how they do their
adsense as well in the last instagram
update whether you know it or not
whether you agreed to it or not they
switched in your settings to uh pretty
wild you can't see what they determine
as quote unquote sensitive content so if
you haven't seen our content lately if
you haven't been notified and you don't
know why go into your settings and make
sure that you change your content
setting from don't show me sensitive
content to show me sensitive content you
have to manually go into your settings
on instagram and youtube and change that
from don't show me sensitive content to
show me sensitive content and then you
know another example of the land of the
free land of the free yeah yeah but you
know pat in closing too i mean i think
what we one thing we figured out was
that you know the time to buy your
insurance is when nobody wants it
and if people can kind of think about
that with everything they do right i
mean if everybody wants something maybe
you sell it if nobody wants something
maybe you buy it i mean there's there's
a there's a lot to be made in this
opposite thinking that's the argument
you don't go extreme right you don't go
extreme like you don't get out of
cryptocurrency it's not
come on don't be ridiculous but you know
but you maybe you you tweak and you
adjust when things are like that and
then if everybody's panicked then you
say okay you can buy this fyi i was
looking at the commentary people loved
you thanks for coming up robin this was
great really enjoyed it yeah take care
guys bye-bye
you